alors je vais vous dire j'ai vu plein de
gens euh qui me disaient oui euh vous
attendez que Camille se plante ça c'est
comme la Star Ac la star acade voulait
que ça marche on est très content que ça
marche et d'ailleurs apparemment
une deuxième saison 12 semaines on est
très content parce que c'est le même
groupe que nous et Camille Combal c'est
vrai qu'il y a plein de gens qui me
disent oui Camille Combal qui a mis
combat le Camille Combal alors Camille
Combal je vais vous raconter l'histoire
de Camille Combal comme ça au moins ce
sera fait je vais la raconter une bonne
fois pour toute comme ça au moins c'est
réglé et comme ça j'arrête de voir j'ai
vu dans les combats lista parce qu'il y
a une gay entre les fan zouzes et les
combats distincts euh les séries que
j'aime les j'aime les deux moi en plus
voilà voilà qui qui est sur les réseaux
qui disent oui il aime pas Camille les
jaloux qui est bien déjà entendu je suis
pas jaloux Camille hein voilà imaginez
bien voilà c'est vrai que voilà Camille
Camille moi j'ai j'ai été le chercher il
était sur W9 à l'époque il démarrait ils
avaient arrêté son émission ça plaît
ASAP et je lui ai dit je vais partir de
France 4 pour C8 je le connaissais pas
bien je l'avais connu en fait parce
qu'il m'avait imiter un jour dans son
émission et j'avais vu ça sur les
réseaux ça m'a fait rire j'ai dit je
vais contacter ce gars là et je lui ai
demandé de me suivre sur Direct 8 donc
voilà donc je lui dis est-ce que tu veux
me suivre Direct 8 il arrive pas il
avait rien à l'époque parce que W9 ça
c'était un arrêté il m'a dit allez je te
suis je lui ai dit ne t'inquiète pas tu
vas faire une chronique quotidienne dans
TPMP on a mis
énormément de moyens pour que ça marche
et c'est vrai que je vous le redis
j'avais été voir le patron de Direct 8 à
l'époque il s'appelait art African qui
est maintenant devenu patron TF1 et je
lui avais dit je veux Camille Combal à
mes côtés sur Direct 8 pour faire une
chronique tous les jours de 10 à 15
minutes il m'avait dit non non j'en veux
pas de Camille Combal j'ai vu sur W9
j'aime pas je suis pas fan je trouve pas
ça top ce qu'il fait je pense que c'est
pas le bon choix
moi j'arrivais sur la chaîne donc c'est
vrai que j'arrive pas à le voilà
l'influence que j'ai que j'ai eu
maintenant et c'est vrai que il m'avait
dit que je voulais Eric Dussart qui
était avec nous sur France 4 à l'époque
Eric Dussart avait choisi de ne pas nous
suivre c'est son choix il avait dit moi
je préfère rester sur France 4 et il a
voulu faire une émission seul sur France
4 donc je veux dire avec ça oui il nous
suit pas et moi celui que je veux c'est
Camille Combal et j'y crois à fond je
pense que c'est un vrai talent et j'y
crois laisse-moi travailler ce talent
laisse-moi le produit laisse-moi le
travailler et tu verras que dans
quelques années ça se passera très bien
donc à la fin je lui dis de toute façon
c'est où Camille Combal ou rien sinon
s'il y a pas Camille Combal je signe pas
donc je viens pas sur sur Direct 8 et on
arrête là je veux vraiment les gens que
j'ai ciblé et je veux Camille Combal
donc j'avais dit je veux Bertrand
Chameroy et Camille Combal en entrée
sortie bon il plie il me dit bon bah
allez vas-y bah prends ton Camille
Combal et tu verras dans trois mois tu
me diras que j'avais raison bon
on a prouvé qu'il a vu tort donc voilà
ensuite donc Camille démarre avec moi et
c'est vrai que voilà on a mis des
équipes je travaillais énormément avec
lui sur sur la chronique au départ on
lui a mis tous ses potes avec qui
voulaient travailler il a fait la
chronique on a travaillé sur Camille
Combal et sur le fait de le faire
émerger de le faire progresser tous les
jours on lui a fait faire des prime time
on lui a donné énormément d'émission on
a je vous le dis il en pense quoi fond
ton frère c'est je vois ça sur une
émission norvégienne c'était un été je
regarde des émissions norvégiennes tous
les étés non non mais c'est vrai je
regrette moi ça sur parce que je vois
plein d'émissions de format voilà l'été
je regarde des trucs et je vois ce truc
là ça c'était un segment dans une
émission qui vient de Norvège et je vois
le truc et je dis ça c'est
extraordinaire il en pense quoi ton
frère et j'étais avec mon directeur
général il me dit bah ça serait génial
pour toi je dis non moi je vais pas le
faire je pense ce serait très bien pour
Camille j'appelle Camille je suis en
voie le truc je lui dis il faut faire il
en pense quoi ton frère comment ça le
faire regarde bon qu'il a très bien fait
et c'est vrai que ça a été le succès
voilà qu'on a eu qu'on a qu'il a eu et
d'ailleurs vous savez qu'on payait pour
ce format c'est-à-dire qu'on payait un
droit de voilà de pour se former des
droits pour se former donc on a fait il
en pense quoi ton frère d'ailleurs il en
soit ton frère est toujours chez nous on
fera un jour peut-être un jour avec
Bernard Montiel
non non mais c'est vrai voilà c'est une
énorme succès moi j'adorais cette
séquence et voilà donc on a on a
travaillé on a fait voilà des choses
voilà on a énormément monté et chaque
année Camille disait voilà truc je suis
fatigué voilà donc après je lui ai dit
je lui ai dit bon bah tu fais trois
chroniques au lieu de 5 et je vais te
produire également à la radio je l'ai
mis sur Virgin Radio le matin parce que
c'est moi qui produisait la matinale qui
a très bien marché donc je lui ai dit tu
vas faire la radio le matin et tu vas
faire trois fois par semaine TPMP pour
dans un souci aussi de de développer
voilà l'animateur et de le développer
donc on a tout travaillé avec lui on a
travaillé des mois des mois des années
et il arrive la fin de la saison je le
vois et il me dit je dis qu'est-ce que
tu veux faire je lui dis moi ce que je
peux te proposer je vous dis tout je lui
dis je vais te proposer peut-être je
pense que ça serait bien que tu refasses
la quotidienne à 18h juste avant moi
tu laisses TPMP parce que tu es fatigué
peut-être tu feras deux trois trucs avec
moi on fera des choses ensemble et je te
produis une série ce qui est rêvait de
faire une série sur Canal+ qui voulait
être comédien à la basket donc voilà il
voulait faire une série donc je dis je
te produit une série sur Canal+ je vois
les dirigeants Canal+ il me disent banco
on fait comme tu as dit on est prêt à
luciner le contrat et là donc on est
avec son avocat il y a mon avocat on est
au bureau de mon avocat avec son avocat
avec Camille et Camille je lui dis je
vous jure que c'est vrai je lui dis
écoute je te sens je sais pas si tu as
envie ou pas de le faire ou pas je te
laisse réfléchir mais si tu as envie
j'entendais des rumeurs comme quoi parce
que Hara africain est parti l'ancien
patron de C8 sur TF1 à l'époque il est
arrivé sur TF1 j'entendais voilà ça
c'est vite donc j'entendais que il lui
aurait proposé de faire qui veut gagner
des millions
et Danse avec les stars donc je dis à
Camille si j'entends ça si tu as envie
de faire Danse avec les stars et qui
veut gagner des Millions
dis-le-moi franchement je peux
comprendre je peux comprendre tu me dis
voilà moi ma mère elle a envie de me
voir sur TF1 parce que c'était TF1 c'est
mon rêve d'enfant de faire qui veut
gagner des millions et Danse avec les
stars j'ai aucun problème avec ça
seulement dis-le-moi avant et il y a
aucun problème nous voilà on a des
choses pour toi ici lundi non non pas du
tout franchement je te le dis moi je
veux faire je suis sûr pour ça laisse
moi réfléchir mais je suis chaud pour ça
et puis c'est pas mon truc si c'est si
c'est ça que tu vois pour moi de faire
des jeux sur TF1 c'est pas la carrière
que j'ai envie d'avoir je dis écoute
c'est très bien de faire des jeux sur
TF1 il y a des gens qui ont très bien
qu'ils l'ont fait très bien en faisant
Pierre Foucault il a une carrière
exceptionnelle tu peux avoir une
carrière à la Jean-Pierre Foucault et
c'est ce que je lui souhaite
j'ai plus de nouvelles
et il arrive la fin de la saison et je
vois en arrivant le matin au bureau dans
Le Parisien une interview de Camille
Combal Camille Combal va sur TF1 et il
dit je vais faire danser avec les stars
et qui veut gagner des Millions donc je
l'ai même pas appelé je vous dis c'est
terminé comme ça on s'est pas appelé je
l'ai jamais eu hôtel je l'ai eu après je
l'ai croisé une fois dans la rue voilà
on s'est croisé truc ça va ça va ça va
ça va mais il ne m'a jamais appelé pour
me dire Cyril j'ai pris ma décision je
vais aller sur TF1 donc voilà j'ai pas
d'orage ni rien du tout juste je vous
dis la vérité c'est que ça me fait de la
peine quand j'ai travaillé
un talon pendant des années des semaines
et des semaines et que je vois ce qu'on
fait TF1 aujourd'hui je préférais cent
fois le Cami qui était là qui faisait
des trucs qui étaient exceptionnels qui
montrait son vrai talent plutôt que de
le voir sur TF1 avec des chaussures
Minelli en train lire un prompteur et
faire la grande incruste qui n'était ni
fait ni à faire hier soir alors je vous
dis je n'ai ni l'arrache ni rien parce
que franchement et vous le savez pour
moi franchement tout va bien
sur ces 8 non mais c'est vrai c'est pas
très bien dans le groupe Canal+ jamais
je quitterai le groupe Canal+ c'est ma
famille voilà juste je pense qu'on
aurait ça me fait de la peine quand je
vois un talent qui est gâché comme ça et
je pense qu'il aurait été bien mieux
avec nous parce qu'on l'aurait beaucoup
plus protégé on l'aurait fait faire ce
qu'il voulait faire et là je pense qu'il
fait qui qu'il a pas envie de faire
derrière donc il a dû rejoindre à
aprilian et derrière et en plus j'ai
plus rien contre lui parce que je vais
parler derrière il s'est associé avec
Arthur voilà Arthur en plus j'ai plus
rien contre lui voilà bah à l'époque
c'est vrai que c'était la guerre avec
Arthur donc il s'est rapproché d'Arthur
il s'est associé dans sa boîte puisque
voilà donc voilà mais je n'en veux pas
comme j'ai dit moi c'est juste ça me
fait de la peine quand tu donnes tout un
gars et que tu lui donnes je les fais
rentrer chez moi je l'ai invité en
vacances je l'ai travaillé des années et
des années pour qu'il devienne ce qu'il
est
ça me fait aussi un peu de peine dans
les interviews qu'on se voit que Cyril
Hanouna ça devient Voldemort il ne
prononce jamais mon nom mais c'est vrai
il vous a pas appelé quoi
il y a un truc aussi c'est que les gens
ont la rassera de moi
il vaut mieux quand même vous appeler
que ça se passe mal au moins dans une
conversation
parce que comme je vois beaucoup de
choses partout je préfère vous dire la
vérité après j'ai pas donné contre lui
et je souhaite vraiment le meilleur
juste j'ai de la peine de voir ce qu'on
a fait TF1 et ce qu'il est en train de
faire et je vous dis c'est comme si vous
aviez un frère et que vous le voyez
partir et vous dites ils sont en train
de le gâcher c'est plus de la peine j'ai
pas du tout de rage contre Camille ou
coquette j'ai pas envie qu'il se plante
ça me fait plus de peine sachez-le quand
il se plante Camille vraiment parce que
je me dis c'est c'est gâché c'est c'est
con que voilà je sais crémant à qui je
suis très proche il a suivi un peu toute
l'histoire avec moi voilà et même toi tu
l'adores comme moi je l'adore parce que
je l'ai écouté à la mettre la matinale à
la radio je le kiffe quand il était là
je le kiffais pour moi énormément de
talent il a rien à faire comme ça à se
faire presser comme un citron dans des
émissions comme ça à TF1 et moi il
m'arrivait à peu près à la même histoire
que toi moi je l'ai toujours kiffé
Camille j'ai toujours envoyé des textos
j'ai fait une en pense quoi Camille avec
lui c'est la première fois que je
faisais de la télé il m'a toujours
chaproné il m'a il m'a toujours donné
des bons conseils et là où que ça fait
la même histoire que toi quand il est
parti bah en fait je l'avais appelé pour
son mariage je lui avais dit
félicitations pour son mariage j'ai
jamais eu de réponse après il avait
perdu son chien je vais m'envoyer un
texto pour son chien après il a perdu
ses clés
non non mais moi ça moi tu sais comment
je suis j'aime bien aussi être soldat
j'aime bien quand les gens m'ont aidé à
un moment donné j'aime bien toujours
être là pour eux tu vois donc et j'y
avais jamais eu de réponse et j'avais
pas compris et voilà donc après il est
peut-être comme ça peut-être que c'est
qu'il s'en va il a matinale maintenant
peut-être que Guillaume partira avec des
gens non non mais moi je trouve qu'il a
énormément de talent je te rejoins je
trouve que c'est énormément gâché et moi
je connais Camille je sais ce qu'il est
capable de faire et de ne pas faire et
un moment je sais comment voilà je sais
comment le travail je l'ai travaillé
pendant des années et voilà si on était
on était très tu le sais Guillaume je se
sent très triste en tout cas non non
mais moi je le connais pas non mais ce
qui est vrai c'est que vous êtes
quelqu'un en vrai de très fidèle
professionnellement moi ça fait 6 ans
qu'on travaille ensemble et quand je
suis arrivé j'entendais mais tu verras
chez Cyril tout le monde parle il vire
tout le monde etc moi tous les gens que
j'ai connu à 6 ans sont encore là en
fait et vous êtes extrêmement fidèle et
merci d'avoir mode de m'avoir donné ma
chance que son production à l'antenne et
franchement voilà je comprends que ça
vous fasse de la peine